and and i think part of this that was
really interesting to me is
uh the way you found the college campus
market
uh you let's say did things that maybe
other founders wouldn't be willing to do
and so talk a little bit about uh your
what was it six or 12 months
basically living on college campuses and
kind of what you were doing
yeah i mean you know my whole thing is
you know vertical networks right and if
you really want to get
to know a vertical you kind of have to
be at one with the vertical
you have to really embed yourself you
have done you have to really get to know
it and
you know i you know explained a bit of
my past now like i barely went to
college i went to mcgill
in canada but like i dropped out um
schools in the us are very different
than canada
or anywhere in the world for that matter
um
and we hired
you know an ex you know one of the
founding team members of the
yak which was another popular social
network back in the day and but
i i still needed to be i needed to be
there so i said to myself i'm going to
spend six to 12 months
and literally go every school that we're
going to launch ends
and speak to people and i'm like a 28
year old dude just like
walking around wearing like all black
and like
you know oxford mississippi and people
are like who the hell is that guy
and because that's where we started we
started in the south you know
i get the feeling that they're like hey
who's the old guy dressed in all black
i remember like i was i was actually in
oxford
and i was at you know end of the day
sitting at a bar
i just for whatever reason wearing a
black hat
you know black james purse shirt and
then these like black jeans with like
black john varvatos converse
shoes and i'm in this like bar and like
i was just on my phone i look up and i
just see like
everyone is like it's like 80
mostly guys wearing like polos stretch
up
socks like you know didn't fit in and
like people were looking at me but like
you know i think i think that's what you
have to do like if you really care about
like
crafting a business and trying to
understand and you have to
go there like i mean you know did i want
to be in oxford mississippi like
drinking a bud light you know surrounded
by like
80 80 dudes named chad and brad
um looking at me funny like absolutely
not but i
i wanted to win that's what ends up
happening
and uh ultimately what happens
ultimately what happens with the
business is
um i go out there to raise money um i
want to raise a lot of money
i get offered a little bit of money and
i was just like all right
i you know i'm a go big or go home type
of guy like all in
you know i didn't move to silicon valley
to
to like not go big on this
um and so i just reached out to 15
um potential acquirers and gotten you
know a few offers got the best one and
we sold to
to wework to basically power their
social networking experience
uh pre-ipo and i joined as a head of
product strategy
there so a lot of people don't know this
but what you just said is a very
difficult but wise decision for founders
which basically was
um and i was privy to some of your
thought process at the time
uh so i can cheat here a little bit but
it takes a certain amount of capital
to do the things you need to do in order
to take something that was
you know starting to work into kind of
working to now hey you got to slam on
the gas and you've got to
drive that momentum to scale nationally
very quickly
right and that's basically the
inflection point you were at but it
takes capital
and so when you don't get that capital
there's kind of a
fork in the road you can either say hey
i'll take a small amount of capital and
i'll kind of do my best
or you basically say look i've got deep
conviction in what needs to happen here
and if i can't do that then
it doesn't make sense for me to pursue
this and by choosing the latter
i actually think it's a more responsible
thing to do
right because you're you're locking in
early investors getting a return
and not putting a new investor's capital
at risk with a plan that you're not
necessarily convinced will work to some
degree
yeah that's exact i actually i was like
that's exactly how i felt i was like hey
like
if i raise an extra three million
dollars i'm not sure that the market
i had to ask myself do i think the
market is going to be better in 12
months or worse than 12 months or the
same
and i was like it's probably gonna be
the same like the venture
the venture environment and when you're
a social app company
you need venture capital to survive and
to grow right we talked about in the
beginning you need to grow grow grow
so i was just like you know what if i
can get a return for my investors
um and my team
you know everyone on my team pretty much
bought
houses from the outcome of it you know
that makes
that makes me feel really good so i
think that it's
it's something that you know one thing
founders should do is really like
understand who's who should like from
day one like
make okay you're starting a company
who's the who are the
um seven companies that would are going
to buy your company
and who are the three people that you
need to know at that company
you know they call it the law of 21. how
do you know how do you get those 21
people and know them
from day one you start the company so
that you know for us like
selling the company was just a tech it
was just some texts
right it was like hey like we're selling
hey you know head of
product at xyz company we are selling
the company are you do you want to make
an offer
versus like trying to scramble
for like an intro and it's like
you know they don't know who you are and
you don't have that trust and
i see that's where i see a lot of
founders kind of struggle